البشرية على كوكب الارض. والان
هل ترى ان كل تلك الكوارث تعني
بفلسطين. تبعهم هبوطا ارضيا
بمدينة الاسكندرية. والتي تحول
بعد ذلك انباء عن دوران لب الارض
الداخلي في اتجاه معاكس. ما يعني
لون مياه بحرها الى اللون
الاسود. ولا يزال الحزن يخيم على
عكس دوران الارض وشروق الشمس من
مغربها. ليلحق هذا الخبر بايام
فيه ان قيام الساعة مرتبط بتحول
جزيرة العرب لمروج وانهار. لتأتي
قليلة زلزال تركيا وسوريا
المدمر. وزلزال مدينة نابلس
السعودية. حتى العربية السعودية
لم تسلم من الاحداث المرعبة التي
ثلاثمائة قتيل وانهيار مئات
المباني بالمدينة. سقوط نيزك في
على صحراء الربع الخالي. اكثر
المناطق جفافا على وجه الارض.
بالطرق البسيطة. وبالتالي ستكون
تلك الابنية اول ضحايا اي زلزال
وقت مضى. فالاحداث التي وقعت منذ
عدة اشهر ولا تزال مستمرة جعلت
الا ان مصطلح نهاية العالم قد
ظهر الان كثيرا على السطح. من اي
الان. نهاية الحياة على الارض.
رغم ان مسألة قيام الساعة ونهاية
البشر يؤكدون انها من علامات
الساعة. وان النهاية قد اقتربت.
اقتراب الساعة ونهاية الحياة
البشرية ام ان الامر ليس له
انهم قد سمعوا صوت دوي لسقوط
النيزك على الارض. قرب مدينة
ورغم ان الواقعة لم ينتج عنها اي
ضحايا الا انها تسببت في العديد
العالم باكمله. وسط مخاوف من
اقتراب نهاية وانتهاء الحياة
ما قورنت بما حدث بتركيا وسوريا.
ولكن الامر بالنسبة نابلس اكثر
على مقياس ريختر. ولعلك تقول ان
تلك الدرجات تعد خفيفة جدا. اذا
فلسطين من الاحداث المرعبة والتي
حدثت في الاونة الاخيرة بمناطق
متفرقة من العالم. فمنذ ايام
شهدت مدينة نابلس العديد من
الاجتماعي معلقين عليه بجملة. هل
هو من اثار زلزال تركيا المدمر
اللون الاسود. وسط حالة من الخوف
انتابت سكان المدينة دون معرفة
بزلزال تركيا الذي سبقه بساعات.
لتتحرك الحكومة المصرية من اجل
خوفا من كارثة تسونامي. ولكن بعد
تحليل البيانات الخاصة بزلزال
البحر المتوسط لموجات تسونامي.
ورغم ذلك لم تكن مصر بعيدة عن
على موعد مع ظاهرة مرعبة فقد
فوجئ سكان المدينة بتحول لون
فيديو. وقاموا بنشر الفيديو على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي. مؤكدين
الكرم. ولكن بعد ثلاثة ايام من
تلك الواقعة. كانت الاسكندرية
للارض ليسقط على محافظة الدوادمي
شمال غرب مدينة الرياض. كما قام
عنيف يضرب المدينة. وما حدث منذ
ايام عاد للاذهان الزلزال العنيف
السبب الحقيقي لتلك ظاهرة مرعبة
حتى الان. زلزال فلسطين. لم تسلم
الحياة على الارض. لطالما شغلت
عقول كل البشر في مختلف العصور.
تتوالى على الارض. فمنذ يومين
اخترق احد النيازك الغلاف الجوي
ليتم ربط الواقعة بحديث النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم. والذي اكد
ففي السنة الماضية فوجئ العالم
العربي بهطول امطار غزيرة وسيول
الذي ضرب نابلس اواخر عشرينيات
القرن الماضي. والذي خلف وراءه
بالمنطقة العربية في الاونة
الاخيرة ولا تزال تمر بها حتى
من التساؤلات حول الاحداث
الغريبة والغامضة التي مرت
ام غضبا من الله? وحتى الان لا
تزال مياه بحر الاسكندرية يغطيها
للامطار الغزيرة التي هطلت على
المدينة. اثناء تعرضها لنوة
الظاهرة لا علاقة لها بزلزال
تركيا المدمر. وانما هي نتيجة
العديد من سكان المدينة بتوثيق
لحظة سقوط النيزك وتصويرها
نفس اليوم شهدت مدينة الاسكندرية
هبوطا ارضيا عنيفا في كورنيش احد
حالة من بين سكان المدينة. الذين
ربطوا التشققات والهبوط الارضي
مياه البحر الى الاسود. الامر
الذي تسبب في هلع السكان وتم
تمر ساعات على زلزال تركيا الا
وشهدت مصر ظاهرتين مرعبتين. ففي
تصوير الظاهرة الغريبة بفيديو.
تداوله نشطاء مواقع التواصل
قامت الحكومة التركية بتحذير دول
البحر المتوسط من تعرضها لموجة
والسودان. ولاثيوبيا نفسها. فحجم
خزان السد الضخم يؤدي الى ترشيح
المياه والتأثير على التربة
والقشرة الارضية. بل وحتى على
رعبا مما تظن. فابنية المدينة
ليست حديثة. بل ان معظمها مبني
الهزات الارضية والتي تراوحت
قوتها بين ثلاثة واربعة درجات
تركيا. الغت الحكومة التركية
التحذير. وبالتالي لن مدن دول
تركيا وسوريا. لتدب حالة من
الهلع في سكان المناطق الساحلية
تقتنع اثيوبيا بالخطر وتوقف
مشروع السد. مصر وموجة تسونامي.
تسونامي قادمة. والتي ستكون ضمن
توابع الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
شواطئها. بالاضافة الى العديد من
التشققات الارضية والتي اثارت
اصلاح الارض وكورنيش الاسكندرية.
مؤكدة من خلال خبرائها. ان
ذلك هو سد النهضة الاثيوبي.
والذي كان سببا في تعرض الدولتين
عديدة بان مصر تقع في منطقة امنة
من الزلازل المدمرة. تحركت
مشروع السد في اقرب وقت. خصوصا
وانه يشكل تهديدا كبيرا لمصر
الحكومة المصرية لتنشئ محطات
جديدة لرصد الزلازل. بالاضافة
احمد ملاعب. من ان مصر والسودان
ستكونان عرضة للزلزال المدمر. في
الخطر. فما الذي حدث في مصر?
هبوط ارضي ولون مياه اسود. لم
والاردن ومصر التي شهدت هي
الاخرى ظاهرة مرعبة وسط تحذيرات
كما شعر به سكان باقي دول
المنطقة مثل اليونان ولبنان
تسبب زلزال تركيا المدمر في قلق
كبير للمسؤولين في مصر. ورغم
الارض بالكامل. والذي سيكون
السبب الرئيسي في حدوث الزلزال.
لبعض الزلازل الخفيفة في الاونة
الاخيرة. وعلى اثيوبيا ان توقف
في مصر الى مائة بدلا من سبعين
محطة. ولكن يبدو ان مصر ليست في
مأمن تام من الزلازل المدمرة.
فقد حذر الباحث البيئي الاردني
البشر على انه بداية لعلامات
الساعة الكبرى. متوقعين كوارث
اخرى ستحدث في الارض قريبا. ولم
تمر ايام قليلة لتشهد تركيا
حتى الان. بالاضافة لعشرات
الالاف من وانهيار الاف المباني.
الدوران مرة اخرى. ولكنه سيدور
في الاتجاه المعاكس. ليذهب
بان الامر لا علاقة له بطلوع
الشمس من المغرب اصر عدد كبير من
وسوريا زلزالا مدمرا راح ضحيته
اكثر من ثلاثة وعشرين الف قتيل
على العالم. والكل يترقب النهاية
بصمت. هل هذه تحذيرية للبشر
مدمر? وهل هي على موعد مع موجة
تسونامي? مصر والزلازل المدمرة.
الى المحطات الموجودة مسبقا.
ليزيد عدد المحطات رصد الزلازل
من تعرضها لموجة تسونامي مدمرة.
فهل مصر بعيدة عن وقوع زلزال
ضحيتها اكثر من عشرين الف قتيل.
ونقصد زلزال تركيا وسوريا.
تعتبر احدى علامات الساعة
الكبرى. والتي ستنتهي بعدها بوقت
بنهاية العالم؟ وهل تتعرض مصر
لموجة تسونامي وزلزال مدمر؟ وما
مرحلة مرعبة. مرحلة الحساب
الالهي. ورغم تأكيدات الخبراء
مغربها؟ اجتاحت حالة من الهلع
الشديد سكان العالم. عندما اعلن
تلك الاسئلة عليك مشاهدة دقائق
الفيديو القادمة. طلوع الشمس من
علاقة سد النهضة الاثيوبي بدخول
مصر قائمة الخطر؟ لتعرف اجابة كل
اتجاه معاكس. وبالتالي ستشرق
الشمس من مغربها. الظاهرة التي
التحذيرات لدول البحر المتوسط من
شبح تسونامي قادم. الخوف يسيطر
والانهار تجف. لب الارض يتوقف عن
الدوران ويغير مساره وقد تشرق
باحثون صينيون اواخر يناير
الماضي ان لب الارض قد توقف عن
الكثير من البشر الى القول بان
الامر بداية لدوران الارض في
الدوران بشكل مؤقت. وانه من
المنتظر ان يستأنف لب الارض
علاقة بنهاية العالم?
قليل الحياة البشرية على الارض.
وتدخل البشرية بعدها بوقت في
والتشققات في ارض الاسكندرية
تظهر في اكثر من مكان. رائحة
الشمس من الغرب. الجميع يضحك
بسخرية ليصحو على فاجعة راح
جفاف وامطار شبه منعدمة. وارتفاع
في درجة الحرارة في اوروبا
امكانية تعرض بلاده لزلازل
مدمرة. لنعد بالزمن للخلف قليلا.
السعودية. ومياه البحار تبدل
لونها الى الاسود. الارض تتصدى.
الخوف تسكن صدور اهل مصر. وعالم
جيولوجيا مصري يصرخ ويحذر من
شف هذا شف هذا ما كتلة اللهب
هذه? نعم. انه نيزك يسقط في